Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill bar and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 11th,
2013 how's it going,
Joe?
Okay.
You know,
guess who got a Boston Red sox championship half the other day?
This guy,
this guy right here.
Oh,
I was there from October 7th on.
I'll tell you the mental anguish that I went through as a fan over those 23
days,
whatever the fuck it took them to win it.
But um,
I got to tell you,
I actually don't like the hat.
It's,
it just makes me feel old when I look at it.
It just used to just be the B and then it'd be like,
Oo,
2030 chill pizza.
That's all you needed.
Now they got,
they got the fucking trophy spinning out to the right.
The bees over here.
Right.
It's a fucking mess.
You know?
I don't know.
I just look,
I,
you know what I look like when I put it on,
I look like a,
I'm trying to start a rapping career.
Can I have the middle aged white guy?
Our team won a championship and I kind of sucked in gym class.
But God dammit,
I had heart white dude hat cause they make one of those.
I don't fucking know.
Oh,
I don't know.
Anyways,
I'm,
you know,
not shitting on that,
thought that style of the hat.
I'm just saying,
it just looks dumb on my head.
You know,
I'm white.
Of course I observed sports.
Why would you pick me?
I am right where I'm supposed to be in the stadium.
I'm shitting in the stance.
How about having a little consideration for a rapidly aging balding
it give me a nice boring hat.
What am I fucking Ashton Kutcher?
Is that an old reference me that fucker's in his 30 by now.
I don't know what happened the last 10 years,
but I've noticed it in my act when I go to make references.
I think I brought this up before I was doing a college gig.
So I'm up there,
I'm trying to be hip,
I'm trying to be down.
I Dunno what I was doing and I,
I made a reference,
I needed a reference for,
you know,
a young pup skanky kind of chick.
And I threw up Brittany Spears and dude,
I'm telling you,
absolute fucking crickets.
I got nothing on it.
And then I just did the math quickly in my head.
I'm like,
wait a minute.
Brittany Spears is like a 32 33 year old divorced mother of two at this point.
She's not that 18 1718 year old girl coming out there.
Hi.
Yay.
Yeah,
I pop my plus whatever the fuck she sang it.
A little fucking outfit.
You know,
total entrapment.
Yeah.
Hey,
once she's of age,
can you still go back and jerk off to that video or is that still looking at
kitty?
Yeah,
porn.
Look,
I know in the video she's 17 but right now she's 26 show.
Even if you split the difference,
she's like 23 right.
Um,
anyways,
so then I had to,
like,
I made a reference.
I did dom,
I rare as podcasts and we were talking about,
he busted me when I did.
Oh,
maybe it wasn't as podcast.
I did.
I did standup show down at the laugh factory,
the world famous laugh factory.
Everybody.
All right.
And if you're around the world and you've never heard of the world famous laugh
factory,
then I think you need to become a little more cosmopolitan,
a little more worldly.
Okay.
You got the Great Wall of China,
you got the octa trial and you have the world famous laugh factory on sunset
strip.
Alright,
what run by the always lovely.
Yeah,
Jamie Masada.
And I was down there doing a stand up thing and dom has this cool show where
like,
you know,
you do stand up and then after you'd done,
he comes up and he does these interviews,
which is more,
you just sit there breaking each other's balls and laughing your ass off.
So he called me out on,
um,
Dustin off some old topical material,
but I forget how I dropped into it.
Um,
but I,
I did the whole,
Oh,
speaking of this,
you know,
what's up with Monica Lewinsky?
I mean,
it wasn't that bad,
but it was one of those deals where he busted me and I laughed about it and I,
and I was,
I was reminded of this time in like the early two thousands I was working with
this fucking hack and he was on stage and he just goes out of nowhere.
He goes,
you know,
people are still talking about Oj.
He just,
the Oj Simpson trial was in 90 half of the debt.
The murder happened in June [inaudible] 94 and the trial concluded in October of
95 and it was 2002 and this guy goes,
people is still talking about o j seven fucking years later.
And then he proceeds to do material that wasn't seven years after the case kind
of thing.
It was like this was shit that he wrote while the trial was going on.
And anyway,
so I got to tell that story and I'm at the laugh factory and it's a crowd of 20
somethings and I tell it to dom and I want to say dom laughed but it got nothing
from the crowd.
And then I'm just looking going,
all right,
say like the average person here is 24 that means they were born in 1989 that
means Oj,
you know,
I shouldn't even see me.
He got acquitted,
right.
I never understood that case.
He got acquitted,
but he still had to give everybody all his stuff.
Like they need more evidence to send you to jail for life.
But you know,
to get all his stuff,
including his Heisman trophy,
all the others
side just has to be,
I mean,
come on.
Yeah man.
You know we did it.
Who else?
Wealth would have thought it.
Okay.
And then it's like,
you know the end of the a wheel of fortune.
You dislike.
All right.
For slicing my daughters throat,
I'll take the dinette set for 700 that's disgusting.
Bellows,
a disgusting joke off.
Fuck you.
I got an hour to fill here talking to myself.
Ah,
what would you be talking about?
Six and a half minutes in.
Exactly.
Okay,
so sit back down and your plastic staples chair and you put your head down in
your desk inside of your fucking cubicle.
I don't hear another word out of you for the next fucking 53 and a half minutes.
Okay.
I'm in no mood.
I got to log podcast ahead of me.
And the last thing I need is someone like you getting off fucking up at eight
next to your stapler.
Yeah.
Anyways.
So I'm starting to feel my age.
I mean,
I look,
I look phenomenal despite the top of my dome from just below my hairline down
for my age.
I look phenomenal.
I though,
fuck you.
I look great.
All right.
I've seen other 45 year olds.
It's not a pretty sight.
And maybe it's because they got married and they had a bunch of kids,
right?
And they made them some omelets and the kids didn't finish it because they
didn't have teeth yet.
So then you got to eat there on what's too,
and then you start walking sideways of your house.
You've corny good door GM,
right?
Can you just start using momentum to get to your car?
You know,
you put your belly right on the fucking driver's side door,
leaning against it.
You know,
like a heavyweight fight or trying to wear down his opponent.
He does lean it against your car is you fill in around trying to find your keys
in your pocket.
You literally have to take a break from carrying that bacon,
egg and cheese mass right in front of you.
The fucking suspension,
digging in on the opposite side of the car.
Like when I try to tip my dog over,
you know,
I don't know how difficult cow tipping is,
but trying to tip over a pit bull is practically impossible.
They get low and they put two of their bionic fucking legs on the opposite side
of their body and then they also have like web toes and they just dig into the
carpet.
Isn't that right Cleo?
Oh Dude,
I got to put up this video of her snoring the other night.
Last night.
She sounded like a fucking truck or who just got back from a fucking there and
back trip across the country.
Fuller.
Arby's.
Okay.
Laying on her back.
Fucking face.
Twitch and rem sleep.
It just snoring.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I don't think she got sleep apnea.
I don't know what her deal is.
A fucking lover though.
So anyways.
Okay.
How was I just talking about,
Oh yes.
I look good for my age,
but I'm,
I'm starting to feel it,
feel it with the references.
So the other day I was working,
um,
the hell was,
I had an unbelievable weekend.
I worked a DC,
New York and Philly and uh,
um,
backstage in,
uh,
in New York City at the beacon theater.
All,
alright.
Legendary theater,
uh,
just beyond anything I ever thought about.
I used to go to stand up New York on the upper west side and my whole fucking
thing was just being able to get a spot there first on a weekday,
a scheduled spot,
not to get thrown up,
to actually have my name on the schedule.
He has a 10,
20.
Right.
And then it became,
can I do a weekend spot?
But I,
I,
and you know,
I get off the subway and I'd walk by that theater a zillion times and it never
even dawned on me that a comedian could even fucking play a place like that.
That's how far away that was.
So,
um,
I hope if you were in the era you had a chance to come down there because I'm,
both of those shows were,
uh,
I dunno,
that was something else.
Something else.
So right up there with Carnegie or any of those other things.
And uh,
but there was something about the beacon that just,
it felt like a,
I dunno,
felt like I was at the cellar,
like comfortable was awesome.
So anyways,
yeah.
Jesus Christ.
I forgot what the fuck I was talking about.
Yeah.
All right,
let's back it up.
Just how my brain works.
It goes in a straight line.
So I got to,
you know,
like when you miss an exit and you got a backup back in the day and you'd go
back and look at the sign
that got the car up,
or maybe he just pulled over and your dad got out all pissed off and left his
family of five sitting on the side of the road waiting to be rear ended.
What people didn't text when they drove back then.
So it was,
I guess it was normal.
All right.
Um,
AH,
shit.
What the fuck was I talking about?
I can't remember.
I literally cannot remember anything that I said before.
No Way.
I said a bad joke.
Oj dinette set
Christ and there it is.
And then and then it just hits the fucking beach and now here we are.
We're,
we're in.
We're in a fucking love.
I guess I was talking about eating like Shit,
you know I was doing so well.
I got myself down to about a buck 70 you know I'm watching that UFC the ultimate
fighter,
right?
I'm watching that this season.
Everybody on the show is in shape.
The women are fucking taken it to the next level.
They having some of the best fights of the season and it's making me want to
work out.
And then I went on the road and this is a funny thing,
me,
I went out with Versie right?
And we're not drinking right now.
We're on the wagon,
although I drank and Thursday,
but I'm still,
I still considered on the wagon.
Wednesday I got fucked up and,
and I paid for it the whole day and I was like,
this is stupid.
I got to,
how many times do I have to learn this lesson?
Um,
so I got to tell you guys,
I,
I went to the Rangers game,
the Rangers Penguin's game on a,
okay.
That was that Wednesday night.
I got to tell you what a fucking venue,
you know,
they redid the whole thing seriously after going to,
uh,
the clippers warriors' game,
just being in the staples center because I really love La and I don't look at
the people like that plastic phony or that type of shit.
But I gotta tell you,
haven't gone to that game Sunday night and then gone to Madison Square Garden.
Uh,
just,
you could not compare the atmospheres.
It was just fucking,
I've talked to,
can I stop saying that annoying word?
The atmosphere side of Sadie was just,
it was electric.
Yeah.
But you could,
you could feel there was something palpable in the early,
the BBB,
the pirate literally that was to come.
Um,
that was fucking amazing.
There's just nothing like being in a stadium,
watching a team that has a history.
I'll be it a tragic one,
but it has a history and everybody just grew up watching them and they know the
history of the game.
There's rivalries,
you just,
you feel it,
you know,
it's like gay.
Yah.
It's like one of those home cooked meals that gets better every time you reheat
it.
You know,
like a beef stew.
I'd Gumbo.
Let's throw that out there for the wonderful people down there in New Orleans.
I actually got home sick,
you know,
last night when I watched a little bit of the saints cowboys,
I watched a little bit of the saints cowboys game and um,
when they were shooting down the street,
you know,
there was play that New Orleans music and shit.
And uh,
now Michael's or go on was sitting there talking about how they was shooting
right down canal street.
And I stayed there at the hotel.
There was the hotel,
there's the fucking Harris,
there's a cigar bar.
And I missed it.
But I gotta tell you,
I ended up shutting off the game because I was so tired.
And I,
what did,
I ended up watching this documentary on Dr Jay on the NBA channel.
You guys got to see it.
Of course,
I don't know the name of it,
but uh,
just on there,
they don't never made one like that.
Never again before or after.
Just the combination.
That guy was so fucking cool.
It's so classy.
And even to this day,
you want to talk about a guy aging,
well,
you know,
they said that he,
uh,
he can still dunk and I'm not going to say whether or not he proves that he can
still do it,
but you definitely should watch the documentary of the shit that the guy was
doing,
especially with all you guys from the Jordan era or maybe the Colby era who just
went just as far back as Michael Jordan if you want to
how Michael existed or whatever is because he got to,
I mean,
aside from obviously all his hard work and all that type of stuff,
but he got to watch a guy like,
like doctor Jay and uh,
they showed all the classic shit,
his dunk on Michael Cooper.
MMM.
And then that one where in the 1980s finals,
what he drives baseline jumps up in the air and he's got the ball,
I think maybe in the third row,
sort of doing this sort of windmill thing swooping around.
And he's literally,
his momentum carries them out of bounds is some giant white dude.
And I don't know if it was Karima,
who else just completely took away that side of the rim.
It was over.
So anybody else,
even an all star,
maybe the best they could do is maybe look to see,
find somebody open underneath the basket to pass it to them or do the playground
thing where you try to throw it off a defensive player and it's out on them.
Right?
But instead he just keeps flying through the air.
All right.
There's two tall people blocking this side of the rim.
I think I'll just keep gliding through the air.
I'm starting to come down,
so I'll pull my legs up a little bit.
Give me this,
give myself a little more hang time.
Comes back all the way to the other side of the basket,
everything.
But probably,
you know,
his halfway to his right forearm,
down to the tip of his fingers is out of bounds the other way and he just
reaches back in bounds at the last second.
It puts like a reverse spin on the ball for a reverse layup on the other side.
I can't explain it.
And it goes by so fucking fast.
You have to watch it in slow motion.
Um,
they got that.
They got all the Aba highlights and the stuffed,
they were given away like they had a dollar night or something like that,
that Nassau Coliseum where the New York nets plague when he was in the Aba and
it was a dollar a ticket.
9,000 people showed up.
And if you showed up,
not only was your ticket only a dollar,
they gave away a free loaf of bread.
So then you start to see all that,
all that will Ferrell semipro stuff.
It's just,
it's awesome.
And I'm actually looking it up right now,
doctor Jay documentary.
MMM.
I guess it's just called the doctor watch NBA Tvs,
the doctor full documentary.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
It's already up online.
This is fucking sons of bitches.
Definitely check it out.
And then they got all these awesome commercials
with all the fucking seventies music.
They had this one,
it goes,
hey,
hey.
Dot j where'd you get those moves?
You move with such grace.
Are you a member of the human race?
They literally go,
are you a member of the human race?
Like you'd pull it,
political correctness would never let you get away from that with the underlying
racist comments.
What they were really trying to say was,
we've never seen anybody play like that,
but you know,
those areas and countries of course would be like,
you know,
well that's exactly what we were saying,
right?
Team.
I guess the Nazi guys would talk like that,
right?
Do you actually have like a bad German accent?
Like I just did,
but you got to see it,
but you got to watch that commercial.
I'm going to,
I'm going to put a link up for that because then the dude,
the second verse that they don't show in the documentary,
he goes up into that fucking seventies falsetto.
It's the shit.
And they loved it.
She like was like memorizing the song and was walking around our house singing
it last night.
Um,
which is why I love her.
All right,
so there's that.
So definitely check out,
uh,
the doctor on the NBH.
I'll watch it on the NBA channel.
All right.
Help out that zillion dollar business with they're mobbed up refs.
So anyways,
where the hell are we?
Oh my God.
Where did the last fucking 12 minutes golf?
It shifts really flies by when you're having fun.
Okay.
Time to do a little bit of advertising.
All right everybody,
here we go.
Bill's going to try to read out loud once again this week.
Is there any improvement,
any improvement at fuck.
I'm already thrown it off the rails.
All right,
here we go.
Focusing,
taking our time relaxing,
maybe going a little slower,
letting it breathe.
Dollar Shave Club,
everyone for a couple of bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing quality razors right to your door.
Not only does it save you a ton of cash,
it saves you from trudging to the drug store for a pack of blades.
I always get stuck behind the lady paying with Darla loose change from the cat,
from the car ashtray.
Actually that's not true.
I get,
I get stuck behind the people who wanted to,
not only by some,
uh,
I dunno stuff for their dentures.
They also want to develop some film and buy some ice cream in the place I go to,
you know,
only has like two employees,
so that one person has to do all of it.
So that's,
that's who I get stuck behind.
But let's pretend it is me.
It's like she's thinks exact changes the requirement.
I'm a patient person,
but heck,
I came in with with scruff,
now I'm leaving with the full beard.
But now with dollar shave club for just a couple of bucks a month,
amazing quality razor blades are delivered right to your door.
That's right.
No more wasting time and no more getting hit up for 20 bucks.
Every time you buy raises.
Everybody here is getting that dollar shave club blades and you should too.
And here's a genius idea.
Try replacing your old shaving cream with Dr Covey's easy shave butter from the
dollar shave club.com.
Trust me,
your face will thank you later.
Don't waste time at the drug store behind the lady paying and Penny's.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash burr or go to [inaudible] dot com and
click on the dollar shave club Banger.
Keep your stress level low and your bank account.
Hi,
I'm shave time shape money.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash.
Birth.
All right,
just for the record,
I think I screwed up three times.
That's not bad.
Let's see if I can,
my this is like golfing.
See if I can take a stroke off on this one.
He voice.
If you are an entrepreneur,
two things keep you up at night.
Increasing revenue and controlling expenses.
What about the gold digging whores sleeping next to you?
I'm Eva.
Boyce is a simple technology that helps you do both.
How?
Let's start with revenue.
Ie voice helps you make sure that everyone who calls your business is treated
like gold.
You get your own toll free or local number.
You can set up a dial by name directory or have calls instantly routed anywhere.
Your cell phone,
your house,
your partner or assistant or all of the above.
Ie voice even transcribes your voicemails and emails them directly to you.
So you can prioritize when and how to respond without interrupting your workflow
with he voice.
You can never leave money on the table.
Just go to the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com and click on the voice banner
or go to [inaudible] dot com slash billboard bill birth.
Dammit.
He voice also cut your expenses by acting as your business phone system and your
receptionist.
That technology could save your business.
Hundreds of thousands of dollars.
He voice starts at only 10 bucks per month and for that plus you can get a toll
free.
Ah,
Shit.
Plus you can get free 30 day trial right now.
When you go to the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com and click on the voice
banner or a voice.com bill bar slash Belper that's my website,
[inaudible] dot com and click on the voice banner or to [inaudible] dot com
slash built birth.
You gotta be kidding me.
I was like three quarters of the way.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm going to have a perfect game.
And then I messed up once.
I'm like,
well,
I'm still going to beat three.
Then I had to and then I'm like,
don't blow it.
Yeah,
God dammit.
So that was three again.
Let's do one more here.
Let's see if I can only make two screw ups.
I'll have to go a little slower.
Put a little more twinkle in my eye.
Hulu plus everyone.
You've probably tried hulu.com now with Hulu plus,
you can watch your favorite shows any time,
any where Hulu plus let you watch thousands of hit TV shows and a selection of a
claimed movies on your television or on the go with your smartphone or tablet
and all it all streams in HD for the best viewing experience with Hulu.
Plus you can watch your favorite current TV shows like Saturday night live
community and family guy.
You can also check out exclusive content including Hulu originals,
like the awesome starring Snl Seth Meyers and Moon Boys' starring Chris O'Dowd
from bridesmaids.
Hulu plus also offers a great selection of a claim to films for only seven 99 a
month.
You could stream as many TV shows and movies as you want wherever you want right
now.
You can try Hulu plus free for two weeks.
When you go to Hulu plus.com/bill that's a special offer for my listeners.
Only make sure you use Hulu plus.com/bill so you can get an extended free trial.
And they know we sent you,
go to Hulu plus.com/bill
now or click the Hulu plus banner on the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com.
All right.
I think that was the only two mess ups,
possibly three.
All right.
Anyways,
let's get back to the,
uh,
let's get back to the old,
the old podcast.
They'll Rooney there.
Um,
so as I mentioned all this week they had the New York comedy festival,
which was why I was at the,
uh,
I was in New York City working at the beacon theater.
Um,
however we were sober.
This,
this is my weekend.
I worked Dar constitution hall where Eddie Murphy Tape Delirious and Chris Rock
did I think never scared or shoot the Messenger.
I forget which one.
Um,
so I got to work that place and then I did the beacon,
you know,
which is the beacon.
And then I got to do the tower theater in Philly.
So,
um,
it was insane.
It was absolutely insane.
And this is my,
we couldn't have gotten any better,
um,
because it was the New York comedy festival.
There was all these big name comics that were in town.
And,
uh,
Bill Cosby was working at the theater down in Madison Square Garden.
And,
uh,
it was on my bucket list.
You know,
I got to see this guy.
I saw Carlin,
I never saw a prior.
I have to see bill Cosby.
Um,
I saw Don Rickles earlier this year.
And,
um,
you know,
there's a lot of people that I should have seen throughout my career and I never
did because I was too busy trying to get better myself.
And I was always like,
I'm going to see him,
I'm going to see him.
And like,
like I never saw a Carlin when I was actually a standup comic where I could have
appreciated them even more.
I saw him in,
um,
I told you this story before.
I'll tell it again real quick.
Me and a buddy of mine psalm at the Cape Cod Melody Tent.
And we actually went down there to laugh at him,
if you can believe it because my buddy had convinced me that he was still doing
his more stuff bit that he hadn't changed up his stuff.
So we were driving to the venue,
drinking and laughing,
going more stuff like we just would like,
but going to go down there.
We actually used to go out,
like I went and I saw a live taping of the Morton Downey jr show.
We would go out to go see stuff like that to enjoy it and also laugh at the
people that,
that thought it was great stuff.
Morton Downey,
Judy was great,
but come on.
It was a shit show,
right?
Uh,
we saw dice.
Um,
we love dice.
We saw him at the worst or central.
We didn't go down there to laugh at him by any stretch of the means.
We went down there to fucking laugh my balls off and we did.
Um,
so he met the Worcester Centrum,
but we went to go see Carlin.
We went down there to laugh at him,
think he was going to do well is old material.
And of course we go there and he had a brand new killer hour and he was 10 times
the comic that he was the last special.
Just how he just kept growing throughout his whole career.
So anyways,
but I never saw him when I was an actual standup comic.
I saw him when I wasn't a comic swell.
I knew it was just,
this guy was funny as hell.
Um,
so anyways,
long story short,
I was flying to New York and they had an article in the New York Post that said
that a Cosby was in town and he was doing the festivals.
So I called up and I asked if there was any way I could stand in the back of
Blahblahblahblahblah and just check them out.
And they hooked me up and they actually got me to the side of the stage and I
was thinking,
oh,
maybe,
maybe he'll just walk by and I'll get to shake his head.
No,
I don't want to bug them,
I don't want to bug them.
So I go backstage and of course there's like 40 people standing there because
you want to go,
you got to see bill Cosby.
So I'm standing there and then this woman goes,
hey,
you want to go up and meet him?
And I was like,
meet who?
And she was and I'm like,
Cosby.
And she was like,
yeah.
So she starts walking up towards his dressing room and I'm just like,
I had fucking mud.
I'm walking in mud.
Like I was afraid,
I was afraid.
So I'm walking on when going,
are you sure it's okay?
Are you sure it's okay because this wasn't somebody running the festival.
This was just like a pa that was bringing me up there and it's right before he's
going on.
And I'm thinking like,
it just didn't seem like this was gonna happen.
So she walks up,
knocks on his door,
I hear somebody say,
come in,
that's not him.
And they opened the door and there he is sitting there with one other guy.
And so I walk in thinking I'm going to get an intro from the PA and she just
closes the door behind me.
Now I'm standing there,
it's me,
this other dude,
it bill Cosby,
who the other two was sitting down and I'm standing up.
It caused me,
looks up at me and he just goes,
who are you and me and my heart is pounding.
I'm like,
uh,
um,
Bill Burnham,
I'm a standup comedian.
Any,
any interrupts?
He just goes,
and why are you here?
And I'll go like,
oh my God,
this is the fucking nightmare.
I did want to come up here.
I didn't want to bug them.
I was tongue tied.
I had I,
there was nothing.
I,
what am I going to say?
Why?
Why am I here?
I don't know why I'm here.
I didn't ask to come up here and she just fucking dragged me.
So it's three excruciating seconds
after he said,
and why are you here?
And I'm just sitting there with my jaw on the ground and then he finally lets me
off the hook and he goes,
you are here because I asked you to be,
and then emotions to a chair and goes,
sit down.
So I sit down.
He had no idea who I was.
I think he knew that I was a comedian,
but I,
I sat down and immediately I just had this fucking ear to ear grin on my face
that I couldn't wipe away.
And I just,
as I was sitting down,
I was like,
I got to tell you this is like
meeting the pope.
And he goes,
yes,
but way more entertaining.
I can't do it the way he did.
He just had me laughing and he proceeded to just start talking to me about how
excited he was about as new special and about the way that he shot the thing.
And,
and,
and uh,
the artistic way.
He's like,
you have to see this thing.
And he was saying,
there's no crowd shots.
He goes,
I don't want the camera on my crowd.
leave my people alone.
Let them laugh if they think it's funny,
he goes,
I don't want the camera on them.
And then they get self conscious and they feel like they have to and he
imitates,
they laugh and he does that.
Cause Bihar did that thing.
It was insane.
So then he goes,
he goes,
I'm going to tell you something about shooting special.
And they look to the other guy goes,
I don't think I should tell him this.
Okay.
You know what?
I'm going to tell it.
I'm going to,
I'm going to tell it to him.
And he turns to talk to me.
And right then the door opens and the PA comes back and goes,
Mr Cosby,
are you ready?
And he goes,
Oh yes,
of course.
And he stands up and he walks out.
So I never got to hear that.
That the secret of shooting a special.
Okay.
From a guy who,
I think,
you know,
I,
I've said this before,
I feel like Richard Pryor live in concert and bill Cosby himself run the entire
gamut
of,
it's like too perfect games.
MMM.
I can't,
I can't explain it.
And it's just one,
just absolutely like Cosby's just totally clean.
And then he says,
asshole one time,
but it's totally necessary.
It's just not an ounce of fat in that special just wire to why is it sitting
down killing,
not cursing,
just
like I just,
you couldn't do it any better as far as just a written special all the way to
Pryor live in concert,
which is just like
I don't,
that's just,
I don't know how to describe that style.
Just open free going off now like you don't have your bitch but like
those nights when you're just on as a comic and you just tagging every joke in a
three minute joke becomes a five minute joke in a five minute joke becomes a 12
minute joke and then the next time you do you use,
you said you're thinking about how he did it the last time.
So you're in your head and then your three minute joke that became a five minute
joke now becomes a one minute joke and you burn through an hour of material in
17 minutes and just on stage going,
what the fuck happened?
Anyways,
those are the two.
Perfect,
thanks.
So anyway,
so then he goes downstairs and he walks out on stage and sits down.
He has like a,
you can't even see it.
It's like this clear Mike that I'm almost like,
he would be like typing into on a,
on a keyboard.
So it's hands free kind of thing.
And he sits down almost like a catcher and he's just like,
like he's sitting down on a stoop.
It just does like an hour.
Uh,
you know,
he was only doing like those,
a number of comics that were on it.
Um,
but he just sits down and like he did 30 years ago when I saw him or whenever
the hell it was.
Yeah,
it was 30 years ago.
Just absolutely
just total commander the crowd.
I've never seen anything like it,
but there was so many people backstage talking and,
and that type of thing that,
um,
I still have to go see that guy live because I hear they said when he did his
special,
he did two shows,
both 90 minutes,
both,
all different material.
And I brought that up to him when I was talking to a real quickly,
I still can't believe I'm,
I'm saying this.
Yeah.
When I was talking to bill Cosby and he said,
uh,
and teachers was humble.
He goes,
well,
you know,
I've been doing this for like 50 years.
I should have that much material when you think,
and it's just like,
yeah,
but it's,
that's all relevant.
Yeah.
Okay.
You know,
don't you have any topical stuff that you have to throw at me?
It's just unbelievable.
So,
um,
he's torn,
he's out there.
He's,
yeah,
part of a,
one of the last ones from a generation that taught the rest of us how to do it.
So if he comes to your town,
I can't recommend it enough to go out and go see that guy.
But,
uh,
okay.
Yeah.
So that was my week.
Okay.
You know,
that doesn't suck.
Does I?
Don't think so.
Um,
so what else did I do?
Let's talk about some of the Shit I did with the New Jersey's own.
Paul Versey.
You don't,
I'm actually rooting against the giants.
Not because I hate him,
but because Paul verse,
he said when they were all winch six that they were going to go on a run.
Remember I said that,
you know,
I got to feel,
a dig,
dig,
dig.
It turns,
you know,
so I,
it's not that I don't want to see the giants go on a run.
It's just,
I don't want to listen to Paul tell me that he called it for the next six years.
Okay.
The fact that he's still talking about Cano and all that,
I don't need another thing him going like,
oh,
like when we're both like when I'm 60 and he's 50 I don't want to be listening
to him talking about the 2013 regular fucking season.
Yeah.
That they could go on a run and blah,
blah,
blah.
And also just having watched the giant,
you know,
okay.
Win Against the Patriots in the Superbowl twice when the Patriots had them and
they let them off the hook.
Now I'm not taking away from the giants.
The giants still had to fucking deliver.
And Jesus Christ did they and they all stepped up and they all made a play where
we didn't,
we're satay Samuels dropped
the fucking interception,
you know,
and we Brady to Welker six yards fucking completion that would've gone for first
down in the game is over and you leave the door open for them.
They are just a blessed team.
The fact that you can go oh and six
okay and then when your next two games and only be two games out and his 16 game
season they have a horse shoe buried so far up their fucking ass.
Like they literally,
they could actually win their division starting Oh and six starting Oh and six
as a football team is basically,
that would be like losing your first 50 games as a baseball team go and like Oh
and 50 okay.
Cause what all and aid is half the season so oh insects.
I can't,
I'm not doing the math.
I can't even do the map.
We'll say that's 40% of the season.
There's 162 games.
Yeah
that's 40 loggers go 40 and 40 as well.
That's like losing your first 70 Ah,
gee,
I don't fucking know.
It's like losing a bunch of fucking games and then somehow,
not only do you go on a run,
you like you win your division.
Okay?
It's insane.
Wait to the cowboys win last night.
I got to look it up.
I started watching that doctor Jay documentary.
They will play in the saints.
I'm going to guess no saints at home.
Let's see.
Cowboys,
saints,
this is entertaining,
right?
Listening to some Douche bag.
Look up a score and I'm going to say the saints won.
Jesus.
Did they ever 49 17 what?
The fucks and now they're five and five.
Now fuck this.
I gotta look it up dude.
This is fucking hilarious.
And FFL this little gimme an nfl.com official websites standings.
Here we go.
Standings.
What are they?
A game up now?
Okay,
the giants are three and six,
so that did did two out that you can expect is fucking hilarious.
They're actually tied with the Redskins.
The Washington Redskins.
You want to be a shady yourself?
You want to be ashamed of yourself.
Jesus Christ.
They went,
oh and six,
the giants went oh and six,
and it only took them nine games to catch you.
Oh Wow.
That's suppressing.
We're already nine games into this fucking season.
Fuck.
It just doesn't,
it just goes by too fast.
It's already November.
Unbelievable.
But thank God there's hockey and I'm actually kind of ended the end of the NBA
this year.
Um,
I don't know,
but it's,
it's very hard to,
to stay up on both those leaks because there's so many games and they played
like deck.
Their seasons just completely overlap each other.
Have you noticed that there's baseball,
football,
like people are either baseball,
basketball or baseball,
football,
hockey.
Um,
you know,
if you're going to go,
if you're going to try to watch as much as you can,
and then you throw in the golf and you've got to watch Wimbledon,
right?
I mean,
no wonder the years are flying by and your wife has that angry look on her face.
It's just fly.
Oh,
another one you guys got to watch.
Watch the PAT Summerall documentary,
a football life on Pat.
Summerall that's another one.
Just,
uh,
just amazing.
You know,
and made me feel good about my drinking considering the way they,
people used to go back in the day.
Um,
yeah,
dude,
the dead last Superbowl.
I forget the guy who goes before my time that pat Summerall was paired up with
before John Madden.
Um,
it was just like an open joke that they used to go out boozing,
like kind of like an a dean Martin kind of way.
See Pat Summerall.
Yeah.
Uh,
broadcast team.
Broadcast partner.
There we go.
Let's see if I can find it.
Oh,
Tom Brooke shy?
Or was that the guy's name?
Yeah,
I think it was Tom Brookshires.
And they actually,
before Superbowl 13,
the second time,
the cowboys and the Steelers met up.
They came on the air in both look like shit and talked about how they'd been
there since Tuesday.
The game was on Sunday or something.
Have they been there since Tuesday?
And how they felt like they had been there for there for nine years and we're
just basically openly admitting that they were fucking hung over and felt like
shit.
It was insane.
So those,
those are two documentaries to watch.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
had a great,
great fucking time when I was in Philly.
Um,
whenever I drive to Philly down from New York,
by the time I get into Philadelphia,
I absolutely fucking hate the city.
I just hate the fact that you just can't seem to get off the Goddamn Jersey
turnpike
you got to,
I always take that exit five.
I always take the wrong one.
I got a weave my way through like 12 suburban towns going by a goddamned gazebo
to go to a major city.
It's a major city.
He got four major fucking teams.
I don't understand why they don't have some fucking throughway where I can
continue to drive 70 miles an hour and get to Philly in no time whatsoever.
I know I'm taking the wrong one.
I should take that one.
That's the 30 that you go over the Ben Franklin Bridge.
But I went over that.
That other one,
exit five.
We end up going over like that fucking foot bridge.
MMM.
Can you pissed and you get there and it's like 12 one ways and going in the same
direction.
Then another one going the other way and you're like,
my hotels right fucking there.
How do I get to it?
And you're pissed.
But then you see Mitchell and ness and all the great food in and you're walking
around,
you have a great time.
So anyways,
uh,
we went and we did the shows at the tower theater.
Crowds were awesome.
No,
I'm just fucking awesome.
And um,
oh,
and you know,
it was awesome too with some woman came to my team,
came to the first show and as I was walking off stage,
like handed me a loaf of Pumpkin bread because I uh,
yeah,
I mentioned,
I was talking shit about how good my pumpkin bread was.
So she hands me this loaf of Pumpkin bread as I'm getting off stage and I'm
laughing like,
like,
cause I know why she gave it to me and I'm walking upstairs and she has it
wrapped very professionally.
Like she has cellophane around it and then she has this plastic bag over that
with the twisty,
a twist tie.
And now I'm going upstairs and I walked by the guy,
I go,
look,
there's somebody may be some pumpkin bread and you know,
there's no bar code on it.
There's no governmental shit.
This stuff is not gone through any sort of stuff whatsoever.
So I'll live,
I say to the guy backstage,
I go,
do you got an,
you got to have a rat problem back here.
Can I feed a piece of this to a rat and just see what happens to the rat?
They'll look a little food testing before I biked to this,
make sure there's no weed in it or any shit like that.
And um,
and whatever.
So I went upstairs and I was just like,
I gotta try it.
And,
uh,
it helped.
The person who made it is,
is listening.
It was fucking outstanding.
Outstanding.
Uh,
I'm not gonna say it was better than mine.
It's like saint Cosby's better than prior.
Our pumpkin breads are both coexisting in that stratosphere and it would just
really be a,
it would just be a mess,
a personal,
personal preference.
I got to tell you,
um,
whoever made it made it in and hand it to me,
it was outstanding version.
He had some too and was like,
I couldn't throw it out.
Actually,
Paul took it home to his family.
So I hope the drugs or whatever you did to what aren't in the middle of it
because he has kids,
but it was fucking delicious.
So thank you very much for that.
Um,
it's very nice of you.
and speaking of battling,
which is better,
my pumpkin bread,
your pumpkin bread.
All right.
You're in Philly.
You don't live there.
Or even if you do live there,
how do you end a great night?
Come on.
You gotta go to Geno's or pats for this fucking steak and cheeses,
right?
And I'm sure the people in oh,
football goes,
please.
Jill felt fucking tours drab.
You go to uncle fuckees over here,
but whatever,
for an out of town guy,
that's what I did.
So I go down there and first he's going,
so what should we do?
Should do Pat's or Geno's?
And I'm like,
well,
fuck it.
Why don't we go,
uh,
we'll get one of each,
then we'll cut them in half and we'll,
you know,
trade mix and match,
do a little surf and turf and see which one we like better.
So of course we go,
what?
We got to Pat's first and we order it and it's just one giant fucking steak and
cheese sub and they don't have even have a plastic knife fee to cut it up.
All they have is a spoon for,
I dunno what do you,
cheese fries or something.
Um,
so he's got a tear it in half and I go over to a,
was standing in line at Geno's Amit and half a one of a patch,
right?
I got one whit is what we got and dude,
it was fucking delicious.
Fucking delicious.
So then I go to the,
uh,
Geno's place.
Same deal.
We ordered another one and as I go up there,
I know I,
I'd been there before,
but I never noticed the sign there on Geno's where it says,
uh,
he's got two signs.
One says I'm mad as hell.
I want my country back.
And it's a picture of the,
uh,
the original owner.
I'd really don't want to fuck this up.
Joey Vento and is a picture of him basically on with the picture of just the
lower 48.
And I love how he blows off Alaska and Hawaii.
He wants his country back.
And then below that there's a picture that says,
uh,
this is America when ordering speak English.
And I was just like,
Jesus Christ,
man,
that's like some old school Bronx tale Archie bunker shit.
And
I saw it and I was like,
it was funny to me because there was this table like five Latino people standing
around speaking Spanish or whatever,
eating the food.
And I'm like wow,
that is a testament to how good your fucking food is,
where you could just like openly insult somebody like that.
And um,
well I guess they spoke English shoe cause they did order,
I had a fucking,
no,
I'm just saying that your food is so good that you could be like consulting that
much openly insulting and uh,
people still order it.
So I looked it up and there's this whole thing where this Guy Joey Ventosa son,
um,
Joey Vento passed away and his son took over the business and I guess it was
this guy's dying.
Wish to keep the speak English sign of Geno's still up there.
I'll read you the article real quickly here.
Uh,
it said last week,
uh,
eatery Philly ran a photo of rapper Busta rhymes hanging out at Geno's steaks
and south Philly.
This was all well and good,
but what really caught our interest was an update to the item explaining that
the speak English sign is still being proudly displayed at Geno's because it
preserves pres.
Its preservation was what late owner Joe event.
Jesus Christ,
I'm sorry guys,
because it's preservation was late owner Joey Vento,
his dying.
Wish Gino recently retained Neff associates,
the same public relation firm that began handling the Joe's.
Oh yeah,
the Joe's verse.
Chinks,
racist cheese steak drama.
Oh,
this is a PR firm.
NEFF PR director.
Cow Flood explains the geno science situation in an email today.
Uh,
he says,
as you know,
Geno's is under new management since the passing of Joy Vento,
Gino Vento,
Joey's openly gay son is the new owner and operator.
And I think it's important to inform you that he does not share all of the
polarizing views his father was famous for.
I think it's also important for you to know that we ever attained,
uh,
Joe steaks,
blah,
whatever.
I guess it was this guy's dying wishes.
Dad's dying wish was to keep it up there.
So it son sort of caught in the middle.
MMM,
I dunno.
It's actually an intro,
almost like an interesting piece of history where they have like colored
bathroom only.
We just kind of see
how far we've come yet.
Haven't come that far.
I don't know.
It was,
it was pretty,
it takes a lot to kind of shock me.
I was just like,
Jesus Christ.
And then I felt like,
well,
fuck this place.
I don't want to eat here.
I'll just eat at the other place.
And um,
I just heard,
well that's owned by the same family.
I don't know.
For the record.
I like Pat's better on that night.
So I,
it might be one of those nights where any given night there,
but they're both absolutely delicious.
So then I had to look up this,
the Joe's verse,
Chinks,
racist cheese,
steak drama.
So,
uh,
I look up this one.
By the way,
all of this shit is making me feel much better about being from the Boston area
because we seem to get like other than the south,
like when you talk about racist cities in the north,
people always talk about Boston and I guess there was a place that's now called
like Joe's stakes and whatever.
MMM.
Oh Jesus.
Where the fuck is the thing?
What is the article here?
Okay.
Philly is renaming a cheese steak shop that used to be called chinks.
Um,
all right.
Philadelphia Capitol City of the United States is,
uh,
is great at many things.
It's great at being within a relatively short drive [inaudible] to de
unfortunately two topics.
It is yet to master our race relations and nuance.
Um,
which is why its residents are freaking out.
That a Philly cheese steak shop known since 1949 as chinks steaks has just
changed its name to Joe's steaks and soda shop.
A chinks was names for its original owner whose name wasn't Cenk,
but who boy did he look like,
one according to his grade school classmates.
Um,
the Philadelphia Inquirer notes that the late Samuel Chink Sherman,
so some guy named Sam Chairman had almond shaped eyes,
so everybody called him chink.
Uh,
folks in the shops neighborhood understand why someone somewhere at some point
maybe could be,
could find the well known racial slur inappropriate,
but they stopped just short of admitting that it actually is.
And because nothing flavors meet like a couple of decades of racism.
They pee,
they're pissed that shakes no longer exist.
Um,
here's a sampling of some of the best lines of complaints.
Uh,
back then,
ethnic slurs slipped off the tongue as smoothly as melted.
American cheese.
Cracker barrel hasn't had to change their name.
I mean,
that could be made into a racist thing.
MMM.
Others said the passing of chinks symbolized the neighborhood's decline.
Uh,
if the shop had been named with a slur against blacks,
that would be offensive.
Said Tarell Jenkins,
a 44 year old African American man,
but Chink,
Chink was a nickname.
It could have been a term of endearment.
See,
that's the one thing that I've learned about travel.
It's just people just give a shit about themselves.
So there's an African American guy,
thank you.
Had empathy.
He doesn't give a fuck.
It's not coming in his direction.
It's like Eh,
you know good about a term of endearment.
Sounds like a white dude at that point.
You know what that reminds me of?
That reminds me of a,
back in the day one of those,
you know,
England,
they have that stupid royalty and these kings and queens and Dutches and dukes
and like just all his pomp and circumstance.
I guess they don't make any decisions over there,
but God knows I haven't really run read up on it.
So what the fuck do I know?
But anyways,
they had some sort of Polo club over there and there was some Middle Eastern guy
who was a member and I think he was one of the only Middle Eastern guys.
Everybody else was these,
you know,
blue blood guys at all,
then assessed you was fucking silly,
all have weird ears and fucked up looking faces like Prince Charles,
you know.
And um,
their nickname for him was study.
They call them study.
So that got out and the Pakistanian Guy,
whatever the hell his name,
whatever ethnicity he was,
he said like,
oh no,
it was a term of endearment.
I don't mind.
I just love like,
that's such like a blue blood Rothchild level,
like study,
you know,
like the,
from your chimney,
from the giant fireplace in your fucking manner.
You know,
nobody thinks about it anymore.
First of all,
most houses don't even have fireplaces anymore.
You can't even use them unless you buy an old one that's grandfathered in.
He know them.
They had these old fucking whatever,
whatever the next style house up from a manner is,
you know,
that one that they shoot it from the air and it looks like a public library
except the grounds is so fucking gorgeous.
All the hedge rows to quote led Zepplin if there's something in your hedge row.
Um,
so anyways,
so I was just fascinating for me to read this like
okay.
I Dunno,
it just,
it just reminded me this was like 1950s level sort of racism like,
uh,
like they're reading just shit and kind of being in that environment.
I was surprised that there weren't some people with their hair grease back
standing around like burning trashcan singing Doo wop
had a very Bronx tale sort of vibe to it.
So,
um,
but having said that,
those racist sons of bitches make some great food.
They really do.
And uh,
I've only eight there one time,
so I'm not going to pass judgment other than to say my experience that night,
pat,
Pat's got the leg up.
All right.
But that's a divisional rivalry.
So they play each other twice in one season.
So I got to go back and have another game down there.
It was fucking delicious and I don't regret a second of putting that poison into
my body.
The fucking bread was delicious.
The cheese was all of that toxic,
horrific shit that my body is probably still trying to process and decide where
it should put it in my body.
Um,
I'm telling you right now,
I would do it again tonight and I just had it two nights ago.
It was fucking delicious.
So thumbs up on the cuisine,
thumbs down on the ignorant thought,
but uh,
leaving the sign up.
Yeah.
Um,
I definitely think the name of the place,
if it's racist it,
you should get rid of it.
But there was something about leaving the signup that,
um,
okay.
I Dunno if,
to me I looked at more as like a museum.
Like this was the guy and he was beloved in the neighborhood,
yet he thought this way.
He had another,
he had another sign that they actually took down.
It said Real Americans don't press number two,
which was a reference to,
you know,
if you'd like English,
press one.
Okay.
At Primo Numero dos.
You know,
there's always the,
the fucking,
uh,
pretty my whatever the fuck they say,
is the Spanish.
That one to me was actually funny.
I don't condone it or whatever,
but it was at least,
it was least clever sort of racism.
I just loved that whole philosophy,
you know?
Gimme I want my country back and that's the same fucking guy that if a native
American came up,
you know,
instead I want my country back.
Like,
you know,
this guy would immediately go into some sort of,
I would imagine,
I don't wanna put words in his mouth,
but I imagine he would go on on some sort of fucking rant about how native
Americans were savages,
you know?
Okay.
As we systematically fucking wiped them out,
like a bunch of fucking savages.
So whatever,
it was really interesting and it was delicious food.
Okay,
let's,
let's get to some,
uh,
let's get some,
some,
uh,
some more advertising and then I got to get to the questions over there.
All right,
here we go.
Let's see if I can improve on to screw ups,
legal zoom,
everybody.
There are two reasons,
not one,
but two reasons why now is the perfect time to start your own business.
Reason number one,
the economy is picking up and the longer you wait,
the longer you delay your potential success.
Reason number two,
right now you can.
You can incorporate your business or form an llc@legalzoom.com for just $99
legal zooms online process guides you step by step and you get total customer
support.
It couldn't be much easier.
Legal zoom pro provides self-help services that your specific direction and kick
connect you to an attorney,
but they are not a law firm so you have a pile of money now so you save a pile
of money.
That's for strokes against me.
Get an extra discount and you went to,
when you enter Burr in the referral box at checkout,
I went into the water.
Don't wait on the sidelines while others are taking charge of their futures.
Now is the best time to get in the game and launch your business.
Don't put this off for incorporation,
trademarks,
patents,
and more.
Just go to legal zoom.com right now.
Discount Code.
Bird bird.
That's legalzoom.com discount code burr.
Good Lord.
That was like the shark when he blew the masters.
That was terrible.
It legal zoom doesn't pay me this week.
I understand.
All right,
let's see if I can go nick Faldo on this one.
stamps.com everyone postage meter companies used to have the monopoly on
printing postage.
They could charge you an arm and a leg to print postage from your own office,
but those days are over.
Now you can use stamps.com instead with stamps.com get all the benefits of a
postage meter,
but@afractionofthecostallyouneedisyourcomputerprinterandstamps.com to get
official us postage for any letter or package,
any class of mail plus you'll never have to step inside a crowded post office
again.
Everything you would want to do with the post office,
you can do right at home from your own desk.
It's so convenient.
I use stamps.com to send out my posters,
my DVDs,
my tee shirts,
whatever.
I'm whoring myself out with selling that week and if I can figure out how to do
it,
someone is dumb as me.
You can't do right now.
Use My last name burpee.
You rr for this special offer.
No risk trial plus a hundred $110 bonus offer.
It includes a digital scale and up to $55 free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
burr.
All right,
that was only one screw up his last chance to try to win a major or they'll
always say he could never win the big one.
Vista print everyone.
A business card says a lot about you and your business.
Are you a hardworking landscaper,
a hip and funky salon owner,
a loyal dog,
Walker,
no matter who you are or what kind of business you have.
Vista print.com has thousands of design to say just what you want and today we
just got word of a great offer on their best business cards.
Get 250 of their premium cards for only 10 bucks.
The shipping is on them too.
I created my cards the other day and I have to say I was impressed at how easy
it was.
First,
you choose to design,
you want pick your industry.
There are over 20 or you select a style instead,
like bold,
conservative,
modern,
or retro,
whatever you want.
They got it.
They even have a personal and family section.
If you're looking to create a contact on mommy card,
vista print has so many designs to choose from that you're bound to find one
that says exactly what you want,
just the way you want.
I even stumbled across a Henna Tattoo card.
These guys really think of everything.
Once you find a car,
do you like the design process itself is super easy and fun at text photos or
logos.
You can even change colors,
fonts,
and move things around.
You can be an artist,
so again,
that's 250 high quality premium cards with shipping included.
Just go to www.vista print.com.
Click on the Huertas on TV slash radio button in the upper right hand corner.
It put it in the promotional code bur bur are,
as you check out,
make sure you take a look at the other marketing products they offer.
Like postcards,
flyers,
brochures,
and websites they even could match.
They even match your business cards.
Oh,
they can even match your business cards.
Excuse me.
Get 250 premium business cards for $10 including shipping.
Just go to www.vistaprint.com.
Click on the hardest on TV slash radio button in the upper right hand corner and
put in the promotional code.
Burr B.
U.
R.
Yeah.
Wow.
That was brutal.
I just really went off the rails.
Um,
okay.
Let's close that forever.
Don't need to see that.
Okay.
On to the questions.
Answer the question.
Um,
all right.
Oh,
by the way,
for all you Alabama fans,
congratulations.
You fucking assholes.
That really devastated me.
Uh,
we had you.
I really think if we scored that first touchdown,
it would've been a different thing.
You've got to protect the fucking ball.
Okay.
You know,
and then all of it's done.
They just keep the discipline just went out the window and they'll completely
went off the rails.
Yeah.
You know,
and I just have to say Nick Saban just completely outclassed the way he's
players played and all that and it's absolutely devastating.
You fucking conch.
All right there.
You happy?
Okay.
Should I say yes bill?
I have a 16 year old virgin guy from Texas and really want to go balls deep in a
snatch before college.
Jesus Christ.
He'll rub one out before you text me next time or email me.
Um,
home company is in a week and this girl who I talked a lot last year,
it doesn't have a date because her date didn't want to pay the 150 bucks.
All right.
You got yourself a wounded bird.
Things are looking good so far.
Uh,
when this year started we ha we haven't talked and I've never texted her.
I don't know where she texted me.
I didn't even have her number immediately.
I knew it was going to be about homecoming because it was all about people.
We were talking about,
uh,
that we,
we,
oh fuck.
Because it was all people we were talking about that week.
She asked me to go with,
she asked me to go with her,
but in a way that made me think she was using me so that she doesn't go alone.
Yeah.
There is a bit of that.
She's definitely desperate.
You know,
you kind of like the third string quarterback and they both went down to the
stick and you in there,
so I know what you're saying.
Is she going to let me throw the deep ball or am I just going to have to go in
there and take a fucking knee?
Right.
Are handed off,
go in the I formation or the wish bump.
Anyways,
he said there's a pretty good chance I would get laid if I win.
I told her I think that I would think about it.
Then she offered to pay for the mum and the food.
What is the mum?
Does she really want to go with me?
Should I say yes and the host hopes that I get to slam her cunt.
You know,
dude,
I really can't figure you out.
It's like you're acting like a virgin by not saying yes to this layup and then
you just really talking about her
in a really disrespectful way.
This girl is an angel.
All right?
The fact that she's going to give it up to a fucking 16 year old virgin show,
a little bird respect,
but you might be also,
this might be your insecurity that you are a virgin,
so you're trying to talk really aggressively about something that you might have
a little bit of fear about.
I have no idea.
Look,
this is what you should do.
If you're going to go with this girl,
be a fucking sweetheart.
All right?
Make her laugh.
Fucking dance around the dance floor and have a great God damn time.
And if the opportunity presents itself,
have it all right,
but that's how you go into it.
I mean,
she's already paying for it.
What kind of a fucking man?
I mean,
I guess you're a pimp at this point.
I'm a pimp.
Virgin.
You don't see that very often.
Whatever you're doing,
it seems to be working,
but I just have a little more respect for it.
That's all I'm saying.
All right.
Go in there.
Have a good time.
All right.
What's that?
What does that,
what's that John Med speech that Joe Barton always quotes tonight.
Today will be the greatest day your life,
but only if you win.
So good luck man.
I hope you,
I hope you win.
All right,
there you go.
But be respectful.
God dammit.
All right.
Car purchase process.
Hey there,
Bill.
Mick red,
beard in balls.
MIC,
red beard and balls.
I liked that.
It's kind of like a law firm.
Um,
love the podcast and love the standup.
Have tickets to see you in DC.
Well,
I hope you enjoyed
the show.
I had a,
I had a phenomenal time.
Um,
he said,
my question is about your car purchase process.
When you bought your Prius,
did you do it in salon?
Did you do it celebrity style and send one of your cronies with a scrooge McDuck
style money bag over
oh to the dealership.
Then have it delivered to your place or did you go in old,
old school and negotiate face to face where you one of those assholes who bicker
over a hundred dollars?
Or did you just buy the whole Shebang and make some poor SAP sales guys day?
I asked because I've been selling cars for 10 years.
I find that the people who dicker over the smallest amount of money are usually
the most miserable considering and after the sale.
While the people who pay the most of the happiest customers,
uh,
I'm happiest customers I have and send me all their friends and family,
a fellow ginger and sleazy car salesman.
Um,
all right.
See you own up to it that you're robbing those people.
I tried to,
uh,
I tried to haggle over the price and uh,
I was buying the Prius when gas prices were like forced for something,
a gallon back in like 2007.
So they couldn't keep those things on the lot.
So I was just like,
this is my offer.
Take it or leave it.
And they're like,
well,
we're going to leave it.
And I'm like,
I'm walking out.
I'm Outta here.
And they're like,
all right,
see Ya.
And I needed a car and I was renting one.
That was the thing.
If I had another car,
if I actually had a car that could drive away with instead of a rental that was
costing me money.
So I just said,
all right,
fuck it.
I'll just pay.
I'll just pay it and I'll go do some more standup gigs.
Um,
but just personally speaking,
if you can't knock any money off of the car,
just cause you know that they are fucking you over.
Um,
you know,
one of my buddies does it the best and he is also a salesman and he looks down
on car salesman.
He looks at you guys like,
like hack comedians as far as like being salesmen.
He thinks you're the lowest of the low.
Now listen,
that's not my thought.
That's just his,
he just calls them up and says the car that he wants and the price that he's
going to pay.
And he says,
I'm calling for other dealerships.
You have til noon to get back to me,
does it,
something like that.
And they get back to him and he gets it for the price that he wants because it's
a guaranteed sale.
He's like,
I'm buying a car today and these dealerships,
they can't resist that.
So I oversimplified it because I don't,
I'm not totally,
um,
you know,
informed on,
I always forget how it goes down,
so I can't intelligently present what the fuck it is that he does.
But that's the way he does it.
Um,
but anyways,
I'm actually,
you know,
thinking about,
um,
buying Nia a nice car.
So if any car salesmen out there could give me some tips and present the ins and
outs about how much they do,
mark cause it,
yeah,
I've heard a lot of stuff like the sales slip on the side of the car,
the car,
the price up at the top is what the dealership pays and at the dealership
doesn't pay for any of the options and that type of thing,
which doesn't seem right to me.
I feel like they must get a discount on the options.
What is the discount?
And I also know that they need to make money.
So what's a good,
let's just say if I'm going to go buy a $30,000 car,
all right?
And if I look at that,
the sheet,
it's,
it came in at 22 or 24,
just say 24 and it gets six grand worth of fucking options or something like
that.
I don't,
I don't even know if those numbers make sense.
If you're a car salesman like w w where should I be?
Should I be in the middle of that?
Should I be at 24?
Um,
where should I be?
Let me know and I'll read it on to other people.
All right,
so I guess to answer your question,
um,
I was the guy who just kind of paint,
I'm not a miserable [inaudible] as much as I sound like it.
I'm actually a really,
uh,
I'm a pretty happy guy.
But you know,
I'm talking about how happy you are on fucking stage.
I mean,
it's not really going to be funny.
So if I talk about my frustrations and my fears and my shortcomings,
you know?
Yeah.
That's where the comedy is.
All right.
There you go.
That was a twofer.
Alright.
Human farming,
Billy beer balls.
Um,
have you heard of the concept of human farming?
It really makes a lot of sense.
Instead of primitive forms of slavery,
the population works and proved and produces for the elite class.
The quality of life is terrible because the ends to the means of working is
really just to service a higher system.
You have no idea.
You're a part of this video summarizes it really well.
Sleep well.
So I actually went to go look at this thing,
this human farming and I understand what they're saying,
but they as always,
you know,
they don't seem to,
well I didn't watch the whole video,
but it's like in the 13 minutes,
are they really going to give me a solution?
Um,
and it also,
first of all,
the guy narrating it might be the most arrogant cunt I've ever heard in my life.
I can't even,
I'll click on it right now if you want,
you know,
he's just like,
a lot of people might be confused.
Hang on,
hang on,
hang on.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
I got to get through the Dodge Durango commercial here.
14 seconds.
He,
you know,
he's basically going like,
some people get,
get confused and look at the government as it's this thing that's helping them
out,
blah,
blah.
Are you beginning to understand the cage that you would put in?
Listen to this guy and how you can finally be free.
Wait a minute.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Let me,
let me,
let me get back to the beginning.
Here we go.
This is the story of your enslavement,
how it came to be and how you can finally be free.
Like all animals,
human beings want to dominate and exploit the resources around them.
All right,
so that's the tone this guy takes.
Let's get a little bit further into this thing.
Here we go.
Patient throughout history and it is now reaching its destructive climax.
Human society cannot be rationally understood until it is seen for what?
It is a series of farms where human farmers own human livestock.
Some people get confused.
Shit,
I pulled it away.
Some people get confused.
Here we go.
Listen to this shit,
listen to this,
and talking down to you.
Some people get confused because governments provide healthcare and water and
education and roads and that's,
imagine that there is some benevolence at work.
Nothing could be further from the reality.
All right,
so then he breaks it down and then in the end he goes,
are you beginning to understand the cage that you were in?
Me keeps going.
Some people get confused.
It's like,
dude,
I'm not fucking confused.
All right,
you're arrogant cunt.
You sound like you're up your own ass.
You sound like you're sitting on top of the fucking pyramid.
All right?
You know what?
This,
this type of shit does that.
It doesn't take into consideration.
It doesn't take into consideration mouth breathing,
fucking morons.
That whole philosophy that why does this guy have this much and this guy has
this much that it's always the rich guy is evil and manipulative and undeserving
nine.
Now,
this is shocking to hear for me the way I go off on bankers,
but I'm really going off on the system of banking when I'm doing that.
But like,
you know,
don't you guys have some fucking friends that,
they go to work but they have no direction.
They have no plan and they just sit around and bitch moaning,
complaining about their fucking life,
you know,
and they feel like they did.
They have like this sense of entitlement that they just fucking deserve shit
because well why should this guy be rich?
And I should is because we made me cause he's smarter than you maybe busted his
fucking ass.
Maybe you sit around smoking fucking weed of boozing it up all day.
Like there's no personal responsibility.
That's what I don't like about this thing.
There's no like,
you know,
it's just a hundred percent these people who are running shit are 100% fucking
evil and that all these people who are enslaved are all good people.
Now,
I'm not saying that,
you know,
there aren't absolutely brilliant fucking people,
but because of their lot in life,
they ended up in a sweat shop in El Salvador.
I'm not saying that,
but what I'm saying is everybody in that sweat shop,
you know
is not a fucking,
I don't know what it's not.
It's,
you know,
there's some mouth breathing morons in there.
And this is where it's a bad example cause I'm not condoning sweatshop labor
either,
but I'm just saying go to a fucking sporting event like I did and just be stone
sober.
They just sit around and look at the fucking people.
Okay look at this shit they're eaten.
Look at this shit their drink and look at their behavior,
look at their clothes,
are hanging off their fat fucking asses.
And I know the food supply is poisoned and I know that there's a bunch of
fucking lies and all that type of shit.
But is there any effort on the part of that individual to try to squeegee in
front of their fucking eyes or do they just accept it?
And if you do,
just accept it,
you know,
then how do I feel bad for you?
Okay.
And I haven't said that,
you know,
racism,
all that stuff about,
you know,
your third world country.
I don't condone any of that shit.
I don't get don't sweatshop labor.
I don't condone I it go,
you should pay fucking people and they should.
You know,
they should.
They should be able to live comfortably.
All right.
Obviously I think that I don't condone that Geno's steaks shit day.
This is America's meek fuck fucking English.
I don't condone any of that type of shit,
but I don't,
I don't also go to that so liberal where it's just like,
oh,
look at that drug dealer.
If he had the same opportunities I had,
why he would be a doctor or a lawyer,
it's like,
oh,
why would he work at Enron or be a piece of shit banker?
Why would he continue his scum?
Baggery why when he becomes in my situation,
does he then become an angel?
I grew up in a suburb.
There was called the sacs in my neighborhood.
I sucked at math.
I didn't become a doctor or a lawyer.
I tried to,
I was too fucking stupid.
So I don't go into that pie in the sky and I just can't get past this guy's
fucking pregnant pauses.
Some people are confused.
It's like,
dude,
maybe you'll fucking confused.
Do you have a better idea?
Do you have a better fucking system?
I'm sure you do and you can let me guest in your fantasy that you don't have to
fucking put to a test.
So it's never so it can't be criticized because it's not been implemented.
Let me guess.
It all works out.
We're all fucking arm in arm and racism goes away and everybody has a nice pair
of fucking loafers as they walk out to get their newspaper that was delivered by
a paper boy and now makes 80 grand a year fright.
I don't fucking know.
Whatever.
Watch it now that you're,
you're,
you're polluted with my fucking thought on it.
Some people are candidates confused.
Does that even look at the government and think that there's some sort of the
Netherlands going on?
Just the fact that he uses benevolence,
you know,
making me feel stupid.
What has been Evolent mean?
Is that some sort of fucking,
uh,
I'm doing something for it.
You know what?
I should look it up.
Let's look it up.
Geez.
It just disappeared after the v.
It
gave up on me like,
well,
it can't be trying to get,
he can't be trying to solve a spell.
That word.
Okay.
Benevolence.
So let's go with the,
the,
the Webster's dictionary.
A disposition to do good and act of kindness.
A generous gift,
a compulsory law Levy by certain English kings with no authority.
Then the claim of prerogative.
Oh,
Jesus.
It takes a left turn on definition number three,
doesn't it?
All right,
so I'm think he's using it in the first or second I disposition to do good.
Um,
I had a fucking,
who the fuck knows?
All right.
Anyways,
let's,
let's move on here before we try and solve the world's problems.
You can go ahead and watch it if you want.
Alright.
Naked picture situation.
A sports illustrated.
I liked that one.
It wasn't really insulting.
Um,
oh by the way,
the Celtics were Oh and four before they won their first game.
So I immediately started looking at the draft for next year and which I haven't
done in the NBA I think ever in a hockey guy,
and I have to tell you,
I was absolutely fucking shocked to see that the top 10 draft picks projected
next year,
eight of them are freshmen,
eight out of 10 of freshmen and the other two are sophomores.
Like it's such a tragedy that these guys can come out early.
It just,
I'm being selfish as a sports fan cause I know that they have,
you know,
a lot of people like it's a money situation.
They got to come out to come from a poor family or just a logical thing where
I'm going to risk blowing out my knee playing ball for free or I can go to the
NBA now and get $1 million.
I know it's a no brainer,
but you know,
just back in the day,
he got to watch for years,
you know of a Patrick Ewing or a Ralph Sampson Hakeem Olajuwon you saw those big
men like their,
their college careers overlapping each other and the next great ones you need
thinking,
oh wow,
maybe win a championship at a time.
He's a senior or something like that.
And just to see like the fact that the junior and senior classes have just been
so raided by the NBA draft at this,
not a junior or a senior,
even projected in the top 10 and you're basically going to draft a fucking
teenager to try to turn the Boston Celtics around.
By the way,
I'm ordering the NBA package.
I'm like,
this is when I step up as a fan.
Not when that good that when they buy a title,
but when they suck a bag of fucking Dicks,
that's when I'm going to sit there and watch him rise up from the ashes.
Okay.
Naked pictures situation.
Hey Bill.
Bill.
Hey,
sports illustrated.
I'm in need of some advice,
sir.
Uh,
I have a naked picture situation on my hands,
although it may not necessarily be what you're thinking.
Well,
I'd see the you or your girlfriend,
I would guess.
Uh,
he goes,
so there's this girl,
this lady that to the same graduate
school as me,
and this girl was a real cunt dude.
Don't do this.
If you have a naked picture of her,
don't do it.
He goes,
we're talking pure evil.
She was in school to be a producer and she managed to alienate and demean every
single person that ever worked with her.
She was manipulative and awful to everyone.
Ah,
sounds like she's going to have a successful career.
She gets into corporate America.
All I'm hearing here is corner office.
Um,
she was manipulative and awful to everyone.
Even her boyfriend who she emasculated constantly,
even in front of his friends while that's on him.
Walk out the door.
What are you going to do?
Give you a suplex go fuck yourself.
I got a hand and a world full of pussy.
I don't need you anymore lady.
Um,
now before I continue,
I should probably say that I realized almost immediately how evil this girl was.
So I always kept my distance and never associated with her in any way.
Uh,
so that this isn't personal.
Now let's get to the issue at hand.
Okay.
So he's painted her as completely evil and he's painted himself as being this
even keeled,
rational person.
I like this.
It's almost as though he wrote the email.
Uh,
now let's get to the issue at hand.
I happened to be perusing the Internet one day in the manner that all men do.
Oh,
aren't you an LF eloquent little cunt.
Huh?
You mean looking at fucking porn?
You dancing around this?
I'm,
you know,
I'm starting to think that this woman is innocent and you're actually evil
person as you continue to try to paint yourself as a fucking hero who's a member
of a Polo Club,
you're rubbing one Authia at filthy fucking animal.
I'm not judging if I do it to happily big grin on my face waving at the
government and us as I rub one out as like,
as I actually as I bust a nut,
I say into the camera that I can't see that's watched me.
It's okay.
I did want to run for office anyways.
I say that as I have an org,
has they have a orgasm?
I can't even talk this week.
Um,
anyways,
he said in the manner that all men do and I happened to come across some naked
selfies that this girl took on one of those tumblers devoted to a,
that kind of thing.
If you're curious now my question is without trying to sound like an evil
scumbag,
uh,
probably too late.
Should I do anything with them?
I could probably give a lot of closer and satisfaction by sending them out to
the people she's fucked over in the pat wait,
is,
is it's this girl.
Oh,
that this girl took.
Okay.
Um,
wow.
So she treats people like that during the day and at night she takes naked
selfies of herself.
MMM,
right.
I know this girl.
I all this kind of girl.
All right.
Okay,
here we go.
Let's,
let's just try to pick this back up.
This,
this girl,
she's,
she's like a,
yeah,
she's like that fucking Wall Street guy that's stealing money and night it needs
to go to a hooker with a fucking orange ball in his mouth.
He needs,
so I think this girl is uh Oh mate.
Well maybe this is like a narcissistic thing.
Is she taking pictures of herself like she's just this piece of meat or she
tried to look hot.
Yeah,
the human fucking psyche,
man.
It's just fucking insane,
you know,
and our genetic cause I'm out of my fucking mind to,
all right,
let's,
let's continue where I'm one of those.
This is a really great email.
There's so many fucking levels to this.
You guys a bucket tell who's out of their mind,
hear her or you're like,
oh your out of your mind and this girl actually shut you down because you want
to take her out for a cup of coffee.
Um,
okay.
Should I do anything with them?
I could probably give a lot of closure and satisfaction by sending them out to
the people she's fucked over in the past.
To be clear,
I would never do this with someone's pictures that were meant privately from me,
but these were already posted publicly online by her or someone else.
Should I anonymously send out a link to people or just kind of laugh quietly to
myself about the whole thing and keep it under wraps?
Any advice would be appreciated.
Well,
what you're doing as far as like justifying your,
your role in this if you were to do it that they were already up there is kind
of like the drug dealers saying like,
well if I didn't sell the drug,
someone else would.
Um,
so I think you shouldn't do anything and I don't think,
I don't know why.
MMM.
Like what am I trying to say here?
Like what,
what do you think is funny about him?
I mean what is the big deal if somebody wants to put some naked photos of
themselves up there?
They like themselves,
they think they look good.
I don't understand why it's considered like nudity and that type of thing is
considered that way.
Uh,
I mean,
she's doing a porno.
I can see then why she can't get a fucking job at Johnson and Johnson,
but you know,
she got some naked photos.
Who gives a fuck?
She's probably the best shape of her life,
you know?
I mean,
uh,
personally I wouldn't do it.
Oh,
who the fuck wants to look at me naked?
Jesus.
What the fuck it that actually disgusted me?
So anyways,
you know what dude,
don't do that man.
You're just going to be,
you're getting drawn into her fucking world.
Okay.
That if that woman is the way you painted her out to be,
she has a bunch of issues and the best kind of guy she's ever going to attract
as some ball is fucking spineless jackass that she's not going to respect.
Um,
okay.
If I had to guess,
she's a woman who needs a guy to tell her what's what it fucking,
uh,
you know,
put a heart on her,
in the bedroom.
She needs to be face down in the pillows being told,
what the fuck to do did that.
She got some sort of fucking issue man.
But you know,
just be happy.
You're not going to work for if she's out of your life.
Okay.
And she's,
you know,
and if she walks around treating people like that,
she's never going to really develop,
um,
lasting relationships,
meaningful relationships.
Uh,
she's not going to have people in her life that would step out in front of a bus
for,
you know,
so she's never going to get the full human experience.
I feel like that is enough of a punishment.
You don't need to go in there and like that.
That's really like a,
uh,
I know I've vengeance thing is very seventh grade girl and I think you're above
that.
Just,
you know,
just leave them alone and continue to jerk off to them.
You're fucking creepy.
I'm not going to lie to you.
I would too.
I'm not judging you.
Welcome.
Welcome to my level.
All right.
French revolution and bankers,
a high there,
Billy bandwagon.
I've been a fan of the men Monday morning podcast for a while now.
And you are on a crab.
You were on the crab feed podcast.
Oh yeah.
With Jay Lawson on the all things comedy network,
everybody,
he said it reminded me of something pre-revolution France was almost identical
to the way the US is now.
Oh God.
I hate when people keep predicting the demise of this country.
Like they're giving us some sort of insight like people in this country can't
see it coming.
All right.
I'm not saying every mouth breathing more sees it coming.
You know,
anybody who has any sort of intelligence,
we see it coming.
Okay.
All right there,
Mr fucking rubbing your God Damn Chin.
Uh,
actually he's probably an American too.
Um,
all right.
France in 1787,
head grinding,
poverty tax inequality.
It was nearly bankrupt from the seven years' war.
Ah,
and then he writes familiar question mark.
I'm not even gonna read this fucking thing.
You're already so up your own ass.
Wow.
I never looked at it that way.
Wait,
does history repeat itself?
Gee,
you're really onto something here,
sir.
Good fucking Lord.
You know what's funny about this type of shit is this probably isn't even this
person's thought.
They'd probably just regurgitating something else that they've read from a
website,
which I do all the fucking time.
I do the exact same thing you're doing here,
sir.
Except by Nalco.
Familiar some fee people.
Some people are confused.
Why can't people just present a fucking,
I done an opinion without like patting themselves on the back about how fucking
smart they are all the time.
You know,
you're a fucking moron.
Just like me.
Okay,
I'm going to read this and I'm going to,
I'm going to skip over
familiar.
Does that ring a bell pot calling the kettle.
Who?
Ooh.
Ah.
With your fucking smoking jacket.
You all right?
Here we go.
Jesus fucking Christ.
All right.
He goes familiar.
It should be the modern us actually has worse wealth and tax inequality than
1787 France and even pre fall of Rome.
So this is all old shit.
I've already heard this theory a zillion times before you present it and you
know,
and I'm not going to fucking read this and get all fucking depressed because I
understand this.
This is why I got out of conspiracy theory and just got a dog and I'm sitting
here watching the bread and circus of fucking sports like I never have before
because there's no way out of this.
Rather than present this shit to me,
I want you to write back to me and give me your solution.
You give me the fucking solution rather than pointing out the fucking obvious as
you rub your God Damn Chin.
All right?
Okay.
Jesus fucking Christ.
All right.
Sorry.
I was having such a great God damn day.
She's wearing an hour and a half in here.
Milan one week did a son of a bitch this week.
All right.
Uplifting documentaries couldn't come soon enough on the podcast.
A Billy boy loved the podcast and all your specials.
Can't wait to see in Dublin and a few weeks.
You're a good man.
Tell all those other Irish country to come out and see this German,
Irish con.
We're all drink some fucking Bushmills afterwards.
What do you say?
And I
barely read faces.
Um,
I got a hot,
warm and documentary for you since black fish and dirty wars might've got you
down a bit.
I appreciate that people,
I love when you send the documentaries that are eyeopening and make me feel like
I want to kill myself,
but also every once in a while you gotta give me a little sugar.
Um,
so he goes,
they might've got you down a little bit.
Here's some uplifting stuff that's called the pipe and it's about a tiny
village,
um,
in the,
in the west coast of Ireland,
taking on a massive oil corporation and winning.
Oh,
I love it already.
Even if it isn't true.
I love it.
Um,
it focuses on the community's refusal to have a dangerous pipeline running
through their village.
It shows the vicious brutality of the cops against the protestors and in
particular five men who goes,
so go,
goes so far as to serve time in prison,
to get justice.
Dude,
those guys are saints.
That's when you are committed to a cause.
All right.
And that's when you know they should make a movie about you.
And then fucking actors who have personal trainers and microbiotic diets,
you know,
show up with abs and get to play you and your life story that William Wallace
Shit,
you know,
five men who goes so as far so far as to serve time in prison to get justice.
Okay.
That's just fucking,
they don't,
they don't make,
they don't make men like that anymore.
Well I guess they do.
They made five of them on the west coast.
Ireland.
God bless him for once the people win.
And as a recent development in the case has seen the shell oil company have lost
their license for work on the west coast of Ireland.
I'm watching that today.
Today.
Here's the link.
It's up on Youtube.
Everybody,
you should check that out.
It's called the pipe and another one for the full documentary.
Oh,
I guess,
okay.
This is the link for the trailer is on Youtube,
but if you want to watch the full thing,
well we'll have these links.
Um,
if for some reason you don't,
you can't,
if you go to surf for Shit and you can't find it,
like I always do,
it's called www.filmsforaction.org/watch/the_pipe_two zero one zero slash again,
and those are all backslash is by the way
it is it backslash,
right?
Yeah.
Excellent.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Everybody.
Um,
I want to thank everybody who came out to my shows this weekend in DC,
New York and Philadelphia.
It was just,
it was fucking,
I'm going to use the word magical there.
I said it at the risk of everybody,
you know,
coming at me in a homophobic way.
I don't give a shit.
I don't,
I like the twinkle toes,
so come at me that way.
I don't give a fuck.
All right.
It was a magical weekend.
I had a great time and you know what?
It's even going to get more.
It's getting to be even more fairy dust on my career this weekend.
The final leg
of the Billy red state tour.
All right.
Um,
I am playing in Deadwood,
South Dakota.
November 15th,
November 16th,
I'm at the Brady Theater in Tulsa,
Oklahoma.
And then I'm wrapping it up at the Orpheum theater in Wichita,
Kansas.
I will be coming out taking pictures and signing shit and all that.
I apologize to people who came out this weekend,
um,
to the earlier shows.
Um,
a couple of nights I had early shows and I can't go out there cause it's slow
shit down.
And then I get in trouble with the union because they have to go dark.
So I can't go out there and load the other crowd in.
So I really feel bad about that because I actually really enjoy going out and
saying hello to people.
So my apologies to,
uh,
people on the first show of I'm in Philly and in New York.
Um,
and the second show,
that beacon,
I actually came out there late because,
uh,
I had a lot of friends in Chicago,
so I got some guilt about that,
but all right.
The deadwood showed the Oklahoma and Wichita.
I'm coming out after all those shows and a whatever you want to do,
pictures,
autographs,
what are you going to do?
I really appreciate everybody coming out.
It's been a hell of a fucking year and a and then you go and then I got one more
Gig,
southern Connecticut State University in New Haven,
Connecticut on November 23rd and,
and after that I got one last giant tour and that's when I do the European tour
and I'm going to fucking do my best
to fucking murder when I go over there.
Um,
I am really,
I'm amped up for these shows,
man.
I got to finish strong.
And then the last one,
the Wiltern theatre in Los Angeles.
My home city here,
and it's going to be me in the entire Rosebowl Deus is going to be there.
All right.
The Ocean's 11 of the Rose Bowl.
Everybody is going to be there.
It's going to be me,
Joe Barnick,
Jason Law and Andrew Feminists.
That's it.
The four horsemen of the fucking rose bowl.
We're all going to be there.
I'll do and stand up at the Wiltern theater to bring in the new year.
You know,
we'll be smoking cigars,
drinking a one quick thing is scotch.
Before we go home and go to bed and then go to see the granddaddy of them all
the next day.
It's going to be a hell of a fucking night.
That's going to be an unbelievable fucking night.
I'm calling it right now.
If you ever want to see the fucking beautiful knuckleheads that I hang out,
you can see hang out with you.
I'm telling you,
go to that show.
All right.
I'm done with that hype and my own shit.
Here's the final thing here.
Now that the show's over,
don't forget to sign up for your free trial of Hulu Plus Hulu plus lets you
binge on thousands of hit shows anytime,
anywhere,
and your TV,
PC,
smartphone,
or tablet.
Support this podcast and get an extended free trial of Hulu plus.
When you go to the podcast page at [inaudible] Dot Com and click on the Hulu
plus banner or go to Hulu plus.com/bill that's Hulu plus.com/bill okay,
that's the podcast for this week.
They have an excellent week.
Good luck.
God bless.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll see out there on the road.